die runden schild zum skelett das ist
auffällig hey da was geht groß war dann
bisschen was fressen
hey freunde und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen zieht vorstellung ich hab ja
im gestrigen galt gesagt dass heute
eventuell ein video kommt eventuell auch
nicht ich nehme dieses videos direkt
nach dem gaildorfer ich denke am ersten
mal werde ich nicht mehr dazu in der
lage sein irgendwie noch was
intellektuell auf einem gewissen
standard und witziges video aufzunehmen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht hey ich
nehme für euch jetzt direkt noch ein
video auf 121 sieht vorstellung bei dir
daher in letzter zeit echt am aktivsten
seit unter allen videos bei den
zielvorstellungen geht erst einmal ab
wie schmidts katze da kommen alle
möglichen diesmal von small bone und
diesen kanal nicht noch einmal
angeschaut sondern die leute die mir
vernünftig kommentare schreiben da gucke
ich mir noch über den kanal an hey
blabla und scott den kanal in echt cool
also der hat mir da so denkt der hat mir
nichts gemacht aber der hat ein killer
intro so heißt das gold heißt doch der
sieht der typ heißt gold bauer der sich
als ausgräber und es ist gerade eine
weltneuheit
ich möchte es gar nicht so hoch preisen
aber ich gucke mir zum ersten mal den
sieg nicht vorher an sondern guckt mir
den live mit euch hier zusammen an
und was wollen wir erst mal in einer
ganz normalen
region also vielleicht ganz schön ja
sowas verwandelt immer sowas chillige
schöne berge hier haben wir allgemeine
schöne landschaft wird hier das ich mag
ja immer so was nicht so alte sachen
hier so ja hier schöner platz ist man
hier so ein bisschen eingegrenzt kann
man hier auf jeden fall was schickes
bauen natürlich shader auf ihrem start
[ __ ] wenn ihr euch nicht gefällt
klatsche ich euch einfach fällt mein
penis in der fresse dann ist mir egal
jedenfalls hat er mir die koordinaten
natürlich gesendet wir müssen erstmal zu
xc60 und z 230 und zwar sind dort
angeblich pyramide und dort also 60 und
30 natürlich ist man seine figuren nicht
so weit dass man jetzt natürlich hat man
kein stück am fliegen könnte ich mal
ganz kurz quatschen über das mega
projekt passt ganz gut
und zwar megaprojekt ja wir nehmen
nächste woche dienstag abend auf da
werden alle zeit haben und dann kommt
ihnen wir nächste woche die erste folge
höchstwahrscheinlich müssen wir dann
gucken wir die hochladen und ja das erst
mal dazu also hier pyramide co2 oder wie
heißt diese hätten ein geht beschreibt
den kommentare wenn das kind da ist so
krank oder irgend sowas
also das ist erstmal eine pyramide der
das dach ist sogar hier komplett scheiße
ich will dass da oben nicht abbauen und
fällt ein blog runter und fällt auf die
platte und dann ist bleiben weil seine
luft gesprengt deswegen stelle ich am
besten einfach mal eine fackel hinnehmen
uns hier kurz die sachen raus die ihr in
der kiste drin sondern pyramide ist
eigentlich immer so mittlerweile
standard reports war eines seats den ich
vor stelle übrigens heute nicht mit cam
weil die ganzen sachen von allerdings
gerade noch übertragen von minecraft
deswegen möchte hat keine zeit ich immer
gesagt ich nehme es direkt danach auf
vier springen
luft aber natürlich die shader ist am
start zum ausgleich ein baum an der
pyramide man vernünftigen eingang
projekt nehmen wir irgendwann nächste
woche auf da kommt die nächste
die erste folge und anja so da hat die
pyramide zwar wieder hier einen
vernünftigen eingang mehr oder weniger
als außerhalb das sind die sachen die
ihre pyramide waren das beste sind auf
jeden fall zweitmarken diamanti haben
wir noch ein dorf mit einer schmiede und
da ist ein eisen schwer drin das ist der
killer wenn man zum beispiel game spielt
den leisen schwer da man direkt gewonnen
trotzdem ist total blöd oder man als pop
crafter gute sachen
da müssen wir zu x120 weiterfliegen und
689 also fliegen einfach mal ein stück
also wie gesagt habe den sieg wollen
nicht angeguckt macht alles provisorisch
spontan improvisiert wenn ihr vielleicht
mal wollte ich was mache einfach so
drauflos und sagt was einfach mal
epische berger hat er gesagt sind ihr
alter die sind echt episch das ist cool
dass nicht wieder so sachen die ich mag
die schöne landschaft und zum skelett
das ist auch ziemlich hey was geht da
muss man ja ein bisschen was fressen
also hier sind echt über das schlage ich
einmal hier drauf da krachen mir sofort
die framerate auf 14 keller also hier
sind echt epische berge finde ich sehr
schön und jetzt einmal zu z 250 und is
250 einen ganz kurzen der screenshot
weil die berge finde ich echt schön
den start mache ich denn mensch freunde
sagt mir vom wo kann ich ein spiel japan
und sind wieder so leicht einen fehler
von ihr von hier ist doch wunderschön
findet ihr auch schon bei der sachen von
ach so da sind die epischen bergsporn a8
so ich bin zu den falschen koordinaten
geflogen hätte also der meinte dass hier
die epische werke sind
erstmals bonner ist bei 120 iks da muss
ich erstmal nach hinten legen und c 280
haye ist hier acht daten ja sieht man ja
schon
auch hier sind zwei sind jetzt weiß
bonner richter alter
weil sie jedoch zwei tonnen warum sollte
jemand sein
hier sind wirklich zwei bewohnern das
ist ja höchst interessant ist erstmal
ein zombie sport und noch ein zombie da
einfach so in der lava gerade ein
bisschen verrückt
wo ist hier die zwei trainer gehen wir
jetzt eine kita mensch also jetzt kann
der zweite kind eine kiste drin
traurig allerdings halt zweispänner
direkt nebeneinander ist ja ganz cool
auf jeden fall der sieht lohnt sich auf
jeden fall schon mal können ja auf jeden
fall mal eingeben smalltalk einfach beim
kanal vorbeigucken ich bin hier nicht
irgendwie angestiftet angestiftet worden
gegen einen kanal zu zeigen habe den
halten die zuvor entdeckt und sprinter
einfach mega geil ist das lied mein gott
doppelkinn alter jackpot krass viele
sachen also freunde und hier wir haben
einen sketch borner also dem skelett und
zombies bonner direkt nebeneinander kann
man schönes bauen auf jeden fall
jedenfalls ich möchte nur freunde
kulas sieht jedenfalls diamanten das
machten da alles haben wir am start die
wir haben echte wind komplett zugepackt
mit verschiedenen sachen das ist
unglaublich
freunde also m und werden euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich über einen daumen
hoch freuen
eventuell wird er mehr wusste ich wecken
und so ihr provisorisch improvisiert ich
weiß nicht hat man jetzt überhaupt ein
unterschied gemerkt sonst bereite ich
mich einmal ein bisschen vor und so aber
das ist echt interessanter diese
pyramide jedenfalls alltag und werden
mit managen